when you thought the web brigade might
have taken a break to enjoy the sunshine
across
uk no no no they struck a gang
this time the bratty champagne
socialists at oxford university
voted to remove a portrait of her
majesty the queen
from their common room
[Laughter]
members of modern college middle common
room found the image of the uk's head of
state
to be a symbol of colonial history
so what the longest serving
monarch of this country is now somehow
being
casted as a representation of oppression
and therefore someone who should have no
place
in their common room they justify their
lunacy
in saying for some students depictions
of the monarch
and the british monarchy represent
colonial
history ten students in fact voted in
favor
of removing the portrait in some kind of
desperate woke attempt to remove any
possible chance
of anyone being offended
oh really please aren't these students
meant to be
some of the brightest in the world to
think that ten of these
numpties could see the queen as an
offensive image
is beyond any rational thinking
come on this kind of attack on british
culture
should be met with total condemnation
it's obscene people believe that they
have a free pass
to trash british culture but if the same
were to be said about another country
or religion it would be met with total
damnation where's the respect for this
country
it's being eroded by these lefty
champagne guzzlers masquerading as
champions of the people
it actually emerged it was an american
student at oxford
who attempted to cancel the queen
this student has seemingly forgotten
that during the reign of her majesty the
queen
50 countries that were previously in the
empire became independent
she was on the throne as the empire was
dismantled
not forgetting the queen's fights
against the nazis
in the auxiliary territorial service
fighting thatcher
over the sanctions on the racist south
african regime
we should be hosting these conversations
not arbitrarily cancelling heroes like
the queen
let's celebrate our history and heritage
and have balanced conversations about
the stuff
that maybe we're not so proud of the
portrait of the queen
will be safely stored but really the
people who ought to be
safely stored are those who voted for
this
farcical outcome